A corrections facility in Lipetsk, a few hundred
kilometers south-east of Moscow.
Like all Russian penitentiaries, this one
is over-crowded.
Human rights activists complain that way too
many people are being put behind bars, that
it cultivates a so-called "convict-culture"
and helps make Russian society violent.
It's also reminiscent of the Gulag regime
of Stalin's reign.
Olga Romanova of the Moscow foundation "Russia
Behind Bars" says many inmates are the victims
of a justice system rife with corruption and
lack of professionalism.
Her organization tries to help the alleged
victims of questionable verdicts.
"When you think of 'Russia Behind Bars,' we
have this saying: One third of inmates are
serving time for the wrong reason, one third
for no reason at all, and only one third for
crimes they really did commit."
These four Russians were also sent to prison.
They were taken to court for various reasons
and at various times – and all were sentenced.
Now they're talking openly about their time
behind bars.
"First of all they use brutal methods to break
you.
Your psyche and your body are abused and humiliated."
"You can only have one visit every four to
five months.
I didn't know how I was supposed to survive
being separated from my loved ones – without
being able to even hug them."
"The worst were those who died in prison.
While I was there, 18 passed away – about
one every two months.
All because of faults in the system."
"Russian judicial organizations and courts
have simply turned into pencil-pushers.
Justice is the last thing that interests them."
Critics complain that the state itself is
actually creating criminals – just to make
a buck.
"If a police station has arrested a hundred
people in January, you can bet that it won't
have any less in February.
That wouldn't correspond to the national plan.
110 would be better, without a doubt.
Prison works on per-person funding.
The more inmates, the more money the institution
gets.
And consequently the more money for judges,
district attorneys and investigators.
So they claim that there are enemies and criminals
everywhere.
But it's really just about money."
Even President Vladimir Putin has said on
several occasions that the country's justice
system needs to be reformed.
But so far, nothing has really changed in
Russia's prisons.